the careers crashes list is our list of
the
top seven biggest professional flame
outs of
the year so when making this list and
deciding what is or is not a career
crash
we're really looking at people whose
reputations have been
severely damaged and in the past
some of these people we put on our list
they're really unable to recover
professionally from the events that
cause them to crash
we're really looking at every
professional whether that's people in
the entertainment industry
or an athlete or the corporate world or
executives or even
politics we look at a wide range of
people last year we had 13 people
make the list and this year we only had
seven um and that's just
you know a sign of the times it so
happened that
the seven worst in our opinion were men
which i thought
was really interesting we did consider
some women but none
made the cut or had as big of a crash as
all these men did
we're still working remotely and a lot
of companies are even making the switch
to go fully remote
so you may not be seeing thankfully
as much of those scandals as you would
be seeing
prior to the pandemic this year was
really different because
for the first year we had um a
zoom professional crash um that was with
jeffrey tubin
his exposure incident on zoom obviously
led to
him leaving the new yorker which is a
very 2020 thing
that happened you know when people think
of the pandemic
and how a career can come to a halt
they think of zoom mishaps because
that's really the way the world is right
now
and that's a new thing on our list that
i don't think we've ever experienced
we saw a lot of incidents really
centered around
the social justice movement for example
with adam rappaport who was the
former editor of bon appetit right after
george floyd's death there was a big
movement of
a photo circulating of him in brown face
which caused quite a stir on the food
and journalist scene
just brought to light all these
realizations about how
bipoc people are treated at um
publications and led to his ultimate
resignation
same with greg the last minute crossfit
not didn't have a brownface incident but
was making some really off-color
comments about
um black lives matter and and george
floyd and his death as well so that's
been a new trend that we haven't seen
before
i think the biggest crash this year um
would be rudy giuliani
rudy giuliani is a really interesting
character because
he was so high in public opinion
especially right after 9 11 you know he
was called america's mayor
to where he is today where he's kind of
the
the mouthpiece of donald trump um and
has tied himself
and his fate so closely with that of the
president you know there is
so many things that you can say about
rudy giuliani
um but i think the most memorable thing
or at least
the funniest um was his infamous press
conference at the four seasons
in philadelphia which was actually a
landscaping
shop and then shortly after that his
leakage
hair dye possibly incident with his hair
or something running down his face
during a press conference
so it's been interesting to see how many
different scandals he's found himself in
this year my biggest advice um for
people to avoid
being on our career crashes list is to
keep her professional
um no matter if you're you know sitting
at home on your bed
or physically going in somewhere to work
you have to always remember to be
professional
[Music]